Vous savez Hervé, au Crédit Mutuel
ils sont en train d’installer
des outils d’intelligence artificielle
pour les conseillers.
Vous savez Hervé, au Crédit Mutuel
ils sont en train d’installer
des outils d’intelligence artificielle
pour les conseillers.
Mais pourquoi tu parles de banque
avec mon père là chérie ?
Je sais pas, je me suis dis que ça pouvait être intéressant.
Non.
Non, je m’en bats les couilles.
Mais oui.
Tu peux pas parler de météo
comme n’importe qui ?
J’en ai vraiment, rien à foutre.
Ce matin au marché,
Pérette a une surprise pour son crémier.
C’est la nouvelle crème légère
l’Exquise, de Bridélice
Une vraie révolution.
Un goût si frais,
enfin dans une crème légère,
longue conservation.
Ce matin au marché,
Pérette a une surprise pour son crémier.
Qu’est-ce que vous faites là ?
C’est quoi ce délire ?
- Allez-y, goûtez.
- Mais c’est quoi ?
C’est de la Bridélice.
Mais je vais pas goûter de la Bridélice
je vends de la crème, je suis crémier.
Oui, mais elle est bien meilleure que la vôtre.
Vous êtes sérieuse là ?
Vous venez sur mon stand pour dire que votre crème de merde
est meilleure que la mienne ?
Elle est vraiment meilleure et plus onctueuse.
Mais vous voulez me mettre au chômage ?
Je viens à votre boulot moi
pour vous mettre au chômage ?
Le chômage vous guette.
Installe-toi
Ça marche.
Ça sent super bon.
Tu te souviens que je suis végétarienne ?
Ouais, bien sûr.
Non parce que souvent les gens oublient
et je me retrouve avec une omelette.
Pardon, mais c’est sans gluten ?
Donc j’imagine que ça,
tu ne manges pas non plus ?
Non, désolé.
Par contre, je veux bien un verre d’eau.
Ah oui, ça j’ai un verre d’eau.
Elle est déminéralisée ?
Tu te casses.
Tu te barres de chez moi,
je ne veux plus te voir.
Oui.
Pardon.
Barre-toi !
Désolé.
Mais tu vas où ?
Je viens de changer de banque.
On part en weekend à Rome.
Je t’attends dans la voiture.
Mais tu vas où ?
Je viens de changer de banque.
On part en weekend à Rome.
Mais on est toujours à découvert.
Oui.
Donc on part nulle part.
Viens te coucher ?
Oui.
On me demande souvent,
si la première semaine gratuite
est vraiment gratuite.
Oui.
C’est gratuit pour que vous testiez
pendant 1 semaine.
C’est gratuit parce qu’on sait que ça marche
et que ça vous plaira.
C’est gratuit parce qu’on sait
que vous allez pas demander le remboursement.
C’est super chiant, faut renvoyer les produits.
Vous vous imaginez faire des petites boites,
aller à La Poste les renvoyer ?
Non.
C’est à frais en plus.
C’est gratuit
parce que c’est rentable pour nous.
Technologie Skynfeel, la matière innovante.
Ils sont en train de ken là-bas ?
N’importe quoi.
Ah bah si, il vient de mettre une capote.
De quoi ? Je veux voir !
Non !
Papa, mais pourquoi t’as jeté
les Gnocchis par-terre ?
Oui Papa, pourquoi ?
Ils devaient être dans la poêle à la base.
Oui bah là ils sont par-terre.
Oui je sais bien,
je les ai jetés trop haut, c’est pour ça.
Mais pourquoi tu les jetes ?
Pourquoi tu les fais pas glisser dans la poêle ?
Oui c’est bon, j‘ai compris,
je sais, j’ai fais comme dans la pub.
Allez vous m’avez soulé,
on commande des pizzas ce soir.
Yes !
Mon père, il est tellement fort
qu’il élève ses poulets sans antibio.
Bon appétit.
Mais, mon poulet ?
Il est mort.
C’était mon ami.
Mange ton poulet Kévin !
Mais Papa, pourquoi tu l’as tué ?
C’est ta faute.
Fallait pas s’attacher à lui, mange-le !
Non, c’est pas juste.
Mange-le !
Il s’appelait Coco.
Il a souffert quand je l’ai tué.
Et oui après une nuit agitée dans la gorge d’Alice.
une vague d’irritation au sud,
accompagne une pluie de picotement.
Et oui après une nuit agitée dans la gorge d’Alice.
une vague d’irritation
attend elle a fait quoi
Alice hier en fait ?
Ah ouais ?
Attends, ils étaient combien t’as dit ?
C’est pas Versailles ici.
Non, puisque nous sommes à Grenoble.
Il faut éteindre les lumières,
c’est pas Versailles ici !
On va où ?
- On va à Versailles ?
- Non.
Je ne ronfle jamais.
Bah la preuve, Mamie.
Comment je peux me faire pardonner ?
C’est difficile.
Allez Mamie, oui !
Je ne ronfle jamais.
Bah la preuve, Mamie.
Comment je peux me faire pardonner ?
je lègue, toute ma fortune
à mes petits enfants.
Et oublie pas la villa en Corse.
Ouais, j’oublie pas.
C’est Paul.
Il me quitte.
Il faut absolument que j’aille lui parler.
Tu peux me prêter ta voiture ?
Mais évidemment.
C’est Paul.
Il me quitte.
Il faut absolument que j’aille lui parler.
Tu peux me prêter ta voiture ?
Bah non.
Mais il est en train de me quitter.
Faut que je le rattrape.
Je peux t’accompagner si tu veux.
Non, j’ai juste besoin de ta voiture,
pas de toi dedans.
Mais, je rentre comment en fait ?
Tu peux prendre un taxi ?
C’est complètement con.
Et avec Pingui on sait comment
garder notre bonne humeur
avec la marche du pingouin
Qu’est-ce que vous faites dans mon jardin ?
En fait, on a vu des Kinder Pingui
Mais je m’en fous en fait
c’est une propriété privée,
vous allez rien à faire là.
On est vos voisins !
Oui, on veut des Kinder Pingui.
Mais je m’en branle.
Y’a une épicerie à côté,
vous allez en acheter, c’est tout.
OK, j’appelle la police.
On y va.
Je t’avais dit que ça marcherait pas.
Et puis arrêtez avec cette démarche,
c’est ridicule !
Arrête, c’est gênant.
Interruption spéciale.
Accrochage en ville Benoît.
Vous devez être sous le choc.
Non, c’est rien.
Quand même, avec tout
l’expertise, les réparations
vous allez perdre un temps précieux.
Pas du tout, avec MMA Mobilité Premium
c’est simple et rapide.
Envoyez la pub.
Accrochage en ville Benoît.
Vous devez être sous le choc.
Quoi ? Je suis en direct là ?
Avec tout ce qui vous attends,
l’expertise, les réparations
vous allez perdre un temps précieux.
Pourquoi vous me filmez moi ?
Y’a d’autres choses à filmer,
barrez-vous !
Moi j’ai embouti ma voiture,
laissez-moi tranquille.
Ah, on me dit qu’Eric Zemmour,
voudrait intervenir sur le sujet.
Mais je m’en branle de son avis,
barrez-vous, allez filmer autre chose !
Cassez-vous !
Tu éteins ta caméra !
Envoyez la pub.